hier souvenez vous on a parlé de camille
combal on a découvert que les dirigeants
de tf1 il aurait interdit de venir sur
le plateau des pmp
du coup vous me connaissez voilà j'étais
énervé je vous dire voilà ce que je
pense moi même de cette séquence
dans un instant celle en quête de bas du
jour et je vous dirai ensuite parce que
norme ans et j'ai même préparé une
petite chanson voilà lui c'est ara
aprikian plus connu sous le nom du
caméléon
au début des années 2010 l'actuel patron
de tf1 arrive à la tête d'une chaîne qui
démarre dès 8
il repère alors une petite émission sur
une chaîne aujourd'hui disparu france 4
le 8 octobre 2012
tpm paix arrive sur le groupe canal
c'est alors que débute entre les deux
hommes un beau monde d'amitiés
pourtant quand ara aprikian rejoint tf1
tout capote
le directeur des programmes interdite
alors à tous ces animateurs de revenir
dans touche pas à mon poste
même à ce gars qu'on voit chaque année
dans miss france et donc personne ne
connaît le nom le summum est atteint
lorsque tf1 interdit à son nouveau
trublion camille combal de revenir dans
touche pas à mon poste
l'émission qui l'a vu et clore pour le
bel éphèbe de tunis c'en est trop il
déclare alors avec son sens de la mesure
arrêtez de faire les côtes baba aurait
alors reçu une recommandation de son
patron frank appietto sais rien il faut
absolument du des excuses
tu as dépassé les burnes pendant les
bornes alors est-ce que siri drame n'a
pas réellement s'excuser est-ce que cela
tour de tf1 le slip de cyril hanouna a
laissé une trace et surtout est-il vrai
que chaque nuit ara aprikian se produit
sur scène sous le nom de lara fabian
deux postures aucun inspecteur papa va
tenter de répondre et par les chéris
alors je vous dis tf1 réagit tout à
l'heure les bornes ont été dépassées
surtout sur une chaîne qui occupent le
domaine public nous étudions toutes les
voies juridiques possibles et ses 8 a
tweeté aujourd'hui à 16h43 et ce sont
voilà donc l'esprit les riches ont fait
hier soir en direct sur tt pmp la télé
c'est que de la télé camille combal tu
es le bienvenu quand tu veux sur le
plateau sur ces huit les dirigeants de
tf1 ont tout notre respect et alors je
vais vous dire voilà je vous dire dans
deux minutes voilà ce que je pense de
cette affaire vous dites vraiment sans
détour ce que vous en avez pensé et je
vous dirais également mon avis dans un
instant moi ça m'a calmé je crois que
c'était surtout la colère par rapport à
à camille mon ses idées sur tf1 mais
d'abord on connait syrie d on sait
comment vous êtes à quand ça monte un
peu en température vous dites des choses
et vous dit franchement avec le coeur
c'est pas c'est pas une affaire d'état
maintenant je comprends que ça puisse
choquer parce qu'il a des mots un peu un
peu c'est un peu des gros mots quoi
voilà un casque bluetooth un bon mais
bon c'est pas très grave a réagi vers
l'est moi je suis pas du tout choquée
par vos mots et je vais vous dire vous
avez été provoqué vous avez été
extrêmement mesuré voici ce qui vous met
des bâtons dans les roues qui veut vous
tuer qui vous provoque qui vous prend
vos animateurs qui empêche les gars de
venir ici qui vous pousse à bout parce
qu'il vous connaissent c'est eux qui
sont les méchants c'est tf1 vous vous
êtes un gentil bravo c'est réel c'est
vrai que moi je crie beaucoup mais je
suis d'accord avec gilles le ch vous
dire la vérité
moi j'écris j'écris beaucoup c'est vrai
que ça mais il faut savoir peiné tout ce
qui est fait au 6e dont tous les cours
de change dans son témoin là ils ont
voulu nous tuer avec 5 à 7 avec arthur
voilà le projet s'appelait killer tpm p
j'ai beaucoup à vous dire moi ce qui se
passe c'est que j'étais très ami
vraiment avait lavé tarime et lyon on a
choisi on va pas se mentir on a monté la
chaîne ensemble s'est vite on était
ensemble on était 5 heures à 6 heures
par jour nous coller le programme france
4 de heroes exactement il avait piqué le
programme france 4 au passage c'est vous
qui n'aimez pas à l'époque puisque avoue
non mais non mais c'est vrai et je vous
dis moi j'ai été blessé parce que
j'aimais énormément ce garçon c'est
comme si vous êtes avec un pote
voilà vous
ou une copine voilà que avec qui vous
êtes très proche et c'est quelqu'un que
j'avais dix fois au téléphone par jour
on était vraiment tout le monde disait
voilà cyril arras et si on était tout le
temps semble même carole je suis sûr que
vous ne saviez qu'on était tout le temps
ensemble à ras et moi on était on était
collé et c'est vrai que quand il est
parti je croyais qu'on allait rester
potes et il m'a fait plusieurs coups bas
donc moi j'ai pas jugé hier j'ai pas
juger j'ai pas juger l'homme je suis et
surtout les méthodes voilà alors c'est
vrai que j'ai été un petit peu excessif
dans mes propos ça c'est sûr parce que
voilà c'est ce que quand on touche à la
famille et camille combal pour moi voilà
je vous dis c'est la famille c'est un
garçon que je connais depuis sept ans je
le suivais même avant qu'il soit avec
nous sur ces vite j'ai tout fait pour
qu'il vienne sur s'est vite j'étais
heureux quand il cartonnait je lui ai
dit je les ai mis à la radio le matin
sur virgin
j'ai essayé de le mettre à 18h aussi sur
ses vite on a fait plein de choses
ensemble c'est pour moi c'est ça sera
toujours mon petit frère je l'aimais
énormément et c'est vrai que le fait que
camille voilà soit pas autorisé à venir
ici dans tpm paie son émission voilà qui
l'a fait moi je vais vous dire un truc
même dans la bande-annonce de tef il dit
c'est un chroniqueur très connu donc
pour vous dire que c'est la référence
encore à tpm paiement dans la même dans
la bande-annonce de tf1 moi ça m'a peiné
parce que cani voilà vous le savez je
l'aimais énormément c'est voilà c'est
mon petit frère vous le savez vous savez
les relations sont avait on s'appelait
tous les jours on était tout le temps
ensemble leurs 6 et de me dire que
camille combal ne va pas venir non
touche pas à mon poste à cause de tf1
c'est vrai que j'ai pété un câble voilà
et samaa ça m'a extrêmement peinés et
voilà aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui voilà j'ai je reviens pas et
je ne m'excuse pas sur le fait que je
suis pas du tout content que tf1 ne vous
laisse pas avoir camille combal ça
vraiment joli je ne l'exposerai jamais
parce que je trouve ça vraiment c'est
quoi la raison c'est ça va c'est qu'
aucun animateur ne doit venir n'en
touche par la promotion des programmes
c'est plutôt pas mal qui viennent ici
mais pour la progression mais ils sont
où les interdictions de venir chez jean
luc reichmann qui est un super pro
qu'elle va dire si oui ou non sur tpmc
nikos il n'a pas droit de venir
c'est vrai qu'on est en concurrence avec
une autre émission à la même heure mais
franchement et là ça me va bien j'ai vu
julien courbet chez vous il est vrai que
m6 m6 et france télévisions et aucun
problème mais je vais vous dire moi
ouais je lis je laissais vite et canal+
il est où les animateurs faire ce qu'ils
veulent ils peuvent aller faire de la
promo
où ils veulent donc voilà je pense qu'il
faut un petit peu de bon sens c'est que
la télé voilà on peut on est tous potes
en plus ses animateurs souvent ni pauvre
je m'en sers et moi nikos voilà
j'adorerais la boire il a très envie de
venir july met illico ce sursis que
nikos venir me mets pas le cas il peut
pas venir pas il peut pas non lobo vie
mon pote tu prends le droit des noms
mais jamais interdit de venir sur tmc un
rôle est bien joué jean luc reichmann
8,2 me regarde celui d'art potosi ne
peut pas venir
donc voilà je pense qu'il faut arrêtez
arrêtez ces guerres parce que je vous
dire ce ne sont que des guerres
économiques moi vous connaissez je parle
toujours avec le coeur et hier j'ai
encore parlé avec le coeur alors bien
sûr à ma manière
c'est vrai que je vais parfois un peu
loin mais au moins je vous dis je suis
toujours sincère et je ne fais jamais de
coups bas ni de coups dans le dos vous
connaissez depuis des années quand j'ai
un truc à dire j'ai des enfants et je
fais et je suis pas quelqu'un voilà qui
va faire des manoeuvres voilà dans le
dos pour essayer de toucher quelqu'un je
dis les choses voilà donc aaa et xavier
si vous m'écoutez on était quand même
hyper progrès ensemble j'ai essayé de
reprendre contact avec vous cet été de
vous envoyer des sms ou encore envoyer
des sms la voilà vous fermer
complètement la porte est envahie et
d'avoir été la télé l'économie l'argent
c'est une chose mais l'amitié et c'est
plus important je pense qu'on ferait
mieux de se reparler
voilà oui non ce que je voulais dire
nous on vous connaît bien vous avez ce
côté méditerranéen vous y allez on vous
connaissez aussi l'adn de cette émission
touche pas on parle franchement dit des
mots parfois un peu trop fort mais c'est
le côté méditerranéen grande gueule moi
je suis en direct c'est que vous êtes un
homme blessé par cette histoire fait
mais c'est surtout ça qu'il faut retenir
parce que vous n'êtes pas méchant d'être
un gentil donc il faudra aussi le
comprendre je sais que vos
téléspectateurs le savent ça mais c'est
sûr il y avait des blessés je vois tous
les fans aussi qu'ils lisent
kamini le on n'a pas envie de [ __ ]
qu'a mis dans la merde parce que camille
l'adorent et franchement je vous dis je
j'espère qu'une chose c'est que danse
avec les stars cartonne et si ça marche
pas je vous le jure il revient mais
continue sur s'est vite j'ai zappé air
tran est revenu mais en com com comme
julien courbet hier et c'est vrai que
c'est mon frère quand même vrai c'est
l'excellent c'est vraiment ça a été mon
frère pendant des années et là encore je
suis encore son producteur à la radio
qu'il arrive à ces anneaux pour
l'instant c'est sûr et certain
on voit là on a des échos pour l'instant
tf1 chica me convient pas et c'est
camille aussi que ça pénalise parce que
je pense qu'il a envie d'aller
pour son émission radio oui je ne crois
pas m'être qu'a mis dans la panade et je
vous dire pour vous prouver tout l'amour
que j'ai pour ara aprikian j'ai même
fait une petite chance on regarde et
loramyc et passants j'entendais bahia
trop sur moi
à ce qu'il paraît jeter l'insulté mais
s'en rapproche des décharges mais
comment ça tu voulais que je le vois
tous
ce sera ma [ __ ] et moi c'est pas de la
télé après des craintes de m'appeler de
plage tôt
l'un d'eux
tu sais bien qu'avec moi c'est ma marque
bien
tu sais bien d'amérique avec moi j'étais
là bas
alors
on nous envoie ce en tout cas et c'est
vrai que ça a pris des proportions
incroyables voilà mais franchement c'est
que de la télé les mecs et vous me
connaissez voilà moi je dis les choses
et je les tire est toujours dans cette
émission je le dis aux téléspectateurs
je vous jure je vous dis toujours la
vérité et c'est ce qui me vaut voilà
parfois des problèmes mais je vais pas
changer pour ça si un moment on me dit
de dire de jouer un rôle à la télé je
vous le dis j'arrêterai et s'il le faut
gérer très très vite franchement j'ai
pas envie de ça je préfère faire une
chaîne sur youtube où on pourra saluer
plutôt que de mon meilleur des avec des
gens qui vont dire faut faire ça ou pas
ça nicolas j'aimerais avoir ton avis en
tant que patron au saint patron de fiat
dix mois la vérité si j' avais dis ça
parce que si j'avais été aussi violent
envers france télé ça s'est un peu
problématique parce que bernard l'a dit
je vais vous parler de votre coeur mais
encore vendre et on peut pas vous
arrêter vous êtes transparent - quand
vous parlez cela et vous cachez pas dire
des choses extérieures lui-même des
échanges ensemble qu'ils ont toujours
été serrées qui ont également nicolas
qui france n'est pas en reste et les ont
séparés
je sais vous après ce qui m'a gêné dans
cette histoire c'est plus de donner des
noms et s'avère que abandonné aaa ou
gagner ici alors j'aimerais bien dans
les cinq ici ici en fait quand il était
chez nous à l'époque un oeil sur ces
vite voulait gagner c'était des
personnages vous les voyez tout le temps
donc c'est vrai que même pour les
téléspectateurs ils les connaissent et
je vous lis c'étaient des amis et moi je
demande qu'une chose c'est cours
deviennent amis voilà parce qu'il faut
arrêter avec ces guerres voilà parce que
franchement ici ils veulent pas qu'on
ait d'animateur de tf1
nous on s'en fout ya de la place pour
tout le monde on le voit les trois tons
cartonne que ce soit quotidien que ce
soit c'est tabou que ce soit et pmp on a
pas de danger
les trois coups des missions vont
continuer je pense encore pendant quatre
cinq ans avec moi je ne sais pas mais
oui mais franchement c'est vrai donc
voilà n'y a pas de danger on n'est pas
des émissions en danger donc il vaut
mieux voilà qu'on concède faites l'amour
pas la guerre
[Rires]
est-ce que vous quelqu'un pour agir là
dessus oui qualité bah moi déjà je veux
commencer par une phrase c'est les
gentils gagnent toujours et moi je sais
que vous êtes un vrai gentil et que vous
avez vraiment été blessé et est ce que
je voulais dire aussi c'est carrément
donné enfin qui est aussi sincère que
vous à l'antenne je pense personne et ça
je pense que c'est une grande qualité
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de défauts
mais c'est une très belle qualité
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]